as we look out we've got to nice clear
skies as that sun is getting ready to
come up but boy it has been windy and as
we take a look
at some of those wind speeds i just want
to share right quick because we've been
talking about punxsutawney phil and we
didn't think that we had any groundhogs
in nevada but i want to thank tom
o'farrell of boulder city for uh
pointing out he emailed me he said you
know we we kind of do have groundhogs in
northern nevada it's the yellow-bellied
marmot that's right they live in the
northern half of the state
and yeah so they're scurrying around
they live in grassy meadows and near
rocky areas and so it's kind of nice
that we do have some groundhogs but of
course
we wait for mohave max the desert
tortoise to decide when spring has
sprung for us here in southern nevada
nate talks about max all the time
laughlin 44 mile per hour winds southern
highlands 36 mile per hour winds a lot
of neighborhoods like north las vegas
and the airport
have had gusts already to 35 so it is
going to be gusty it's going to be cold
all day make sure that you've got nice
warm jackets with you it's going to feel
like winter punxsutawney phil said yes
six more weeks of winter we've got lots
of 30s around and some low 40's but
those wind chills are going to feel
colder all day long than the actual
temperatures look at kyle canyon even
with some winds to 24 miles an hour
temperatures are in the teens and it
feels like two degrees up there teens
over northern and central nevada this
morning all the way up to reno and
temperatures near freezing in indian
springs 38 in boulder city 46 in
laughlin and yes these winds are going
to be with us we'll keep watching this
huge winter storm that's gathering
through the middle of the country that's
the big weather story today with snow
ice freezing rain and blowing winds our
cold front is well south of us it's the
high pressure rebuilding behind that
cold front that's really cranking the
winds today and all of these areas are
blue are wind advisories the purple hard
freeze warning for mohave county
northwest arizona so northwest winds 25
35 miles an hour sustained with gusts
that could be up to 50 in some areas
especially along the colorado river
valley so we have wind advisories for
las vegas 10 a.m to 7 p.m today this is
uh could blow trash cans down the street
trash in the roads it can even pull down
tree limbs could cause some power
outages today we're going to be dealing
with a lot 50 degrees will never feel
like 50. that's 10 degrees cooler than
yesterday and then we'll stay breezy to
windy tonight and still breezy thursday
so 53 is it for the high we should be in
the low 60s we'll get 60s back by the
weekend and maybe even some warmer 70s a
couple of days next week